(metal music)
- The year is 1988; big
hair and denim are in.
("Seventeen" by Winger)
The ultimate lead singer
in hair metal, Kip Winger,
and his band are at the top of the charts.
But the party that seemed
like it would never end
suddenly came crashing down.
(birds singing)
No air play, no singles, nothing.
But it turns out this
was just the beginning
for Kip Winger.
- This is, uh, you know, at
home with Kip Winger.
(laughs)
This is so exciting.
(banjo music)
- I'm Chris Funk.
I'm a musician in a band
called The Decemberists,
and I'm on a journey looking
for the most surprising
and extraordinary people in music.
My next stop takes me
to Nashville, Tennessee.
There I will meet a rock
legend with one of the most
unexpected transformations in music.
- Hi guys, we're The Decemberists.
We're from Portland, Oregon,
United States of America.
(audience cheers)
A Decemberists tour
brought me to Nashville
where we played the
historic Ryman Theater.
A day between shows gave me
a chance to explore the city
known for its honky tonks and live shows.
But I was here for something
else; to track down
an ‘80s icon.
- What's up?
- Hello.
- I'm Kip Winger, and I'm
in the band, Winger, and I'm
also a classical composer.
At the height of my career,
we were playing for thousands
of people every night and
gold and platinum albums.
Beavis and Butthead was the
biggest show in MTVs history
at the time, and it ushered in a whole
new genre of music, grunge.
And it completely ripped
apart the ‘80s hair bands,
and I was at the scene of the crime.
My name was on the little
geeky guy's T-shirt
that represented everything that sucked.
Lost the record deal, lost the publishing.
I was at my very lowest point.
I did say, well there's
nothing else to do now
except that thing that
I've always wanted to do,
(subtle bagpipe music)
which is really learn how to
wield an orchestra organically.
- To go from a rock bass
player to composer is learning
music all over again.
To do so later in life, as
Kip did, is almost unheard of.
(classical music)
- I could never even
read an orchestral score
until I was 35.
10, 15 years into it to
finally start to hear
orchestras play my music,
and realize, oh my God,
this is really what I'm here to be doing.
- Dude, that's awesome.
Amazing.
- In this case I took a,
I'm calling it a riff,
'cause that's my terminology
from being a rock guy.
(piano riff)
(musical sounds) turns into...
(orchestral music)
It was a scary and lonely path.
I've got a record company
that's going, why are
you doing that?
You're a rocker.
You need to rock.
And I'm like, no, no, no, I
don't need to rock; I need
to be doing this.
This just kind of starts
all on a rock riff, really.
You know, you kinda go
against all odds when you
just believe in something.
- Despite the challenges
with learning how to compose,
Kip's persistence ultimately
led to a Grammy nomination
in Contemporary Classical Composition.
(pleasant music)
- It's very cathartic,
healing experience to overcome
my illiteracy in music
at a late age, with not
so much self-confidence.
It was like, okay, you know what?
I don't suck.
Like, it wasn't true, what they all said.
To be acknowledged with
a composer nomination
from the Grammys was the greatest feeling
of accomplishment of my whole life.
(pleasant music)